We have to talk about this talking point being
used by some on the right and even some on
the left about so-called outside protesters
in the civil unrest that we're seeing across
the country right now in dozens of urban areas.
So I'm going to tell you what's being said.
I'm going to tell you the truth, and then
I'm going to tell you what the most important
takeaway is from all of this, which is that
it doesn't actually matter if protesters are
coming from so-called the outside.
So the right regularly talks about so-called
outside protesters because their priority
is to make it seem like there's not really
a concern in our country about police brutality
in the communities where the protests are
happening.
So when the right insists the protesters are
coming from outside the city from somewhere
else, they can disqualify and ignore the activism
that is actually motivating protesters.
And they can say, you know, these are provocateurs,
these are looters and rioters, burglars, people
who are there for nefarious reasons.
But most importantly, what they want to argue
by saying people are coming in from outside
the cities is they want to argue that not
that many people are actually concerned about
police brutality, which was the catalyst for
these protests.
You've also got a little slice of the left
where you've seen the outside protesters talking
point used in the context of framing outsiders
as the right wing astro turf, whether it's
white nationalists pretending to be an antifa
or in order to make an TIFA and protesters
kind of amorphous or look bad or whatever
else, you're seeing less of it.
But it's still also not the best thing, because
here's the truth.
Number one, in terms of those getting arrested,
the reports that we've seen are that most
of the arrests are people who live in the
cities or metro areas where the protests are
happening.
So in Minnesota, there was a report, about
25 percent of the arrests were outsiders in
Detroit.
Similar numbers, about 80 percent of the arrests
were from the Detroit metro area.
So, first of all, it is factually untrue that
a huge number, at least of the troublemakers
are from outside areas.
But here are the two really important takeaways.
First of all, it would make sense that the
troublemakers, politics aside, are from the
outside.
Why?
Well, there's that phrase about dogs don't
go to the bathroom where they eat or something
like that.
Intuitively, of course, people are more likely
to cause trouble and destroy stuff where they
don't live.
It says nothing about motive or justification
for the protests whatsoever.
But it makes sense that you're more more likely
to destroy a place that you don't actually
live in.
But here's the most important takeaway.
Who cares if they're coming from the outside?
You can still care about police brutality
if you come into a city from somewhere else.
Mass rallies happen in urban centers and population
centers.
Protests happen where there are people.
If you live in northern rural Indiana, there
aren't any sizable protests there because
there's such little population density.
It makes perfect sense that you would head
into Chicago, for example, to be part of a
larger protest.
It doesn't mean you don't care about police
brutality.
It doesn't mean you're there to commit a crime
or to attack people or to loot.
It just means people are protesting where
there are people.
So I was reminded of this debate that happened
around Barack Obama.
This is he really a Christian or is he is
some kind of secret Muslim?
And at some point, Colin Powell came out and
said the question of whether he is or is not
Muslim is irrelevant.
Muslims can still be president.
It would change nothing about his policies
if he were Muslim.
And in the same way here, there is nothing
invalid about protesters from out of town.
Much of this country is very rural.
The protests are limited to a few dozen large
urban areas.
Of course, you're going to have people from
different places in cities protesting because
that's where the protests are taking place.
So we've got to take back this talking point.
We can't allow the right or the left to miss
the forest for the trees.
Just arguing about the protesters are from
in or out of the city.
The looters are from in or out of the city.
People are going to cities because that's
where the protests are happening.
And there's nothing wrong with that.